so one of my primary roles as far as i'm
concerned is to give advice but the
problem is that nobody ever asks for my
advice which means that i have to give
it unsolicited so today
um we're gonna go to reddit's am i the
[ __ ] forum heretofore known as the am
i the a-hole forum where people post
their uh their personal dilemmas and uh
they wanting to know if they or someone
else in the dilemma is uh the a-hole
what the [ __ ] is this so i can identify
an a-hole from a mile away so this
should be easy and we'll start here
am i the a-hole for leaving a family
gathering because my family made me sit
at the kid table
for context i haven't seen my full
family together in quite some time so
they set up a get together at a park
today the family gathering includes me
my brother my sister her husband and
their two kids my dad my stepmom and her
kids aunt uncle my two cousins grandma
and grandpa uh and he's a 22 year old
male i get there with uh not the
grandpa's not 22 year old male but but
the person writing this is i get there
with some picnic items i brought a
quiche and the cups
and i see a few members setting up i say
hi and help set up the tables and set
the food out one problem i'm running
into with already with the am i the old
things it's like way too much
information just get get right to the
point i don't need to know what you all
had for your picnic what does that have
to do with anything
anyway so i sit next to my dad and i get
a weird look from my aunt as she says to
me this is the adults table
to which i reply i'm an adult she says
that the first and second generations
are considered adults
and the third and fourth generation
should sit at the kids table
i tell her that i can drink that i drove
here and then i pay rent and have a job
so how am i still considered a child she
says that until i have kids of my own
i'll have to sit at the kids table
according to my aunt there are eight
children ages six to 22 and eight adults
ages 25 to 75. so i should just sit at
the kid's table uh and then he proceeds
to storm out
and he takes his quiche with him and he
leaves and he wants to know if he's the
adult
uh yes you are i knew it i'm surrounded
by [ __ ] number one because you
brought a quiche okay you're going to a
picnic
what kind of man
brings a quiche to a picnic in the first
place i don't even know if i'm
pronouncing that correctly
uh you bring chips you bring beer okay
or something along those lines
and also you're childish and ridiculous
for storming out
proving by your behavior ironically that
you are worthy of the children's table
at best in fact your
you should be a step that this this
should be like a third table just for
you because uh because my kids are at
the at the kids table and they would and
i would not allow them to act like this
and besides here's the thing you need to
understand as a man and your aunt who
brought this up i think is correct
you aren't going to be fully accepted as
a grown man until you get married and
have kids
that's that's just the way it is i'm not
saying it should be that way
well i mean i am saying it should be
that way but that's not the main point
that that is how people see it
and uh so if you want to graduate to the
to the adult table then you have to have
kids of your own you know you you
basically look at this this way you
supply your own replacement for the kids
table once you have your own kid they
sit there you get to graduate to the
adult table
all right am i the goal for assigning my
family homework and not visiting until
it's done i recently quit my phd program
to get a job because i realized academia
was not what i wanted and i was better
off just using my masters to get a job
everyone i know from school or has
experience with grad school agreed i'm
doing the right thing because i've only
done one year phd classes so it's a good
time to quit i've had to tell people
that this and that and so and so forth
my family were not understanding none of
them have ever been to grad school but
they believe that i was very far along
and quitting at the last minute i've
told them one year of classes is nothing
but they don't realize how hard the exam
and dissertation are okay where does the
homework come in i figured if they
wouldn't listen to me they might listen
to someone else i found an article by a
college professor that describes what
it's like to get a phd in my field
i told them i would not visit until they
read the article and wrote a few
paragraphs summarizing the article and
discussing why someone may choose not to
get a phd
it's not meant to be a long and
difficult project i just want them to
understand my point of view my boyfriend
and my siblings did their essays and
apologized
what
and my boyfriend went above and beyond
by including other sources besides the
article so he i think her boyfriend is
the guy that brought the quiche to the
picnic so this is all it all is this is
all the same universe where this is
happening
my parents still haven't done uh their
essays and haven't apologized and still
complain that i'm throwing away all the
work i did okay
um you're the you're the
you're like double triple a-hole
material here you're just an [ __ ]
first you enrolled in a phd program for
no reason at all and then you quit
you you're the one who didn't do your
homework maybe you should have read that
article before you signed up for the phd
program
and sunk all this money into it for a
year
um here's the thing about phd programs
like master's degree degrees also
in like 98 of cases are giant scams
and that's where you find this uh this
weird kind of like disconnect because
you think of people that have all these
letters next to their names it's a sign
of intelligence no oftentimes it's a
sign of stupidity that you were too dumb
to realize what a waste of time this was
and you did it anyway so
you're the a-hole for that reason
and then you try to give a homework
assignment to your family members
and your boyfriend is also an a-hole for
actually completing the assignment
and so are your siblings i can't i have
five siblings
if i were to tell them here's the
assignment and i need you all write me a
three s three paragraph essay an apology
they would laugh at my face
so
everyone in your family including you
they're all a-holes except for your
parents they're the only ones who come
out looking okay here except that they
raised you
which makes them a host too so this is
just an a-hole bonanza
uh what else we got here am i the at the
a-hole for not wanting the clock in the
car to be five minutes fast
my wife has always kept the clock in her
car five minutes fast ahead of the
actual time i tried this technique in
the past but found it wouldn't work for
me we each have our own car along with a
shared car that the whole family uses it
was driving me that's nuts that i'd look
at the clock remember it's not right
then i have to check my watch to see the
actual time
and then it goes on for another 50
paragraphs but that's basically the
thing
should they have the clock set ahead in
their car
no you're not the a-hole for not wanting
the clock set ahead the setting the
clock's a head thing
is absurd because when you do that
you just end up doing the math in your
head anyway so i don't understand the
strategy you're not actually fooling
yourself into thinking the time is
different than it actually is so you're
giving yourself a math assignment every
time you get in the car uh so no you're
not the a-hole for that am i the a-hole
for forcing my son to call
me mom
oh here's a good one okay
this is a meaty one when my husband and
i wanted a child we decided to pursue
surrogacy instead of a traditional
pregnancy it was a hard decision that
took a lot of late night talks and
fighting because he wanted to be
involved in the pregnancy and everything
but i was terrified of ppd postpartum
depression the postpartum body and all
the morning sickness that came with it
finally we went through an agency to
find a suitable gestational carrier
otherwise known as a human being i'd
like to think we were pretty involved
throughout the pregnancy process and we
somewhat befriended the carrier
befriended the carrier um nowadays we're
not closed by any means but we send each
other birthday and holiday wishes and
such tuesday my son found out about the
surrogacy it wasn't really a secret by
any means but the topic just never came
up he was talking about how he learned
about it in biology how he thought it
was weird i told him no it's completely
normal and that he came from a surrogate
i didn't think it would be that big of a
deal but for the next few days he
started pestering me about the details
of who the surrogate was and why i went
through with it well i told him my
reasons and he took from the
conversation that i was too lazy to have
him myself
yes
he's now insisting that i'm not his mom
my husband told me that it's just a
phase that's probably because our son's
a little raw from an unrelated argument
we had earlier this month however i'm
honestly really hurt and disrespected
that he doesn't think of me as his mom
when i tried to have a discussion about
it he escalated after and now only calls
me by my real name instead of mom his
argument that is that it's his choice to
decide who he wants to call
his parents
i kind of like this kid i gotta be
honest with you
uh no i mean you're not an a-hole for
for forcing your son to call you mom
um
but you are the a-hole for choosing
surrogacy in the first place so that's
where you went wrong but you're an
[ __ ] you rented out a womb
like you're renting a room you know you
treated another person's body like a
like an airbnb
and yeah they they volunteered for it i
mean they like sold
their body to you literally i mean they
sold their womb to you
and because you didn't want to deal with
the physical changes that come with
motherhood
um you're right your son was exactly
correct in fact you shouldn't talk to
his mom that way
uh but but he's right that you were just
too lazy to carry the child yourself now
you're reaping some of the consequences
that your child doesn't feel connected
to you in the same way because he's not
now this is different from something
like adoption
where you're giving up comfort for the
sake of the child you're bringing the
child into your family but surrogacy is
is the opposite
because rather than being born from
sacrifice
it comes from an unwillingness to make a
sacrifice
so i think it's a
i think it's a horrific practice
honestly and uh dehumanizing even the
way you refer to this person the carrier
we befriended the carrier
um
it's terrible and you're the hill okay
let's see we'll do one more
i was in a higher end department store
today
rhymes with looming tales
and uh happened to end up next to two
teenaged girls while shopping one of the
girls had picked out a pair of very
expensive boots they were both fawning
over them the second girl must have
looked at the price tag and asked the
girl if she was really going to spend
that much of the boots the girl with the
boots says something along the lines of
it's fine i have my dad's credit card
i'm not paying which instantly caught my
attention because that's not her card
i've told my son multiple times he's
never allowed to use my card so i'm
interested to see how this girl thinks
she's going to get away with fraud but
i'd split up from the girls at this
point because they had found something
else
we end up at the same register me behind
and i see her total hit well over four
digits the girl's about to swipe her
card when i decide that i can't let her
get away with something like that and
someone has to parent this child if no
one else will i tell the cashier that
isn't her card but her father's and i'm
not sure if she has permission the girl
and the friend turning glare and giving
me the the dirtiest look i've ever seen
i swear this girl was going to throw a
temper tantrum right there
the girl tells the cashier her father
gave her the card to shop with uh but
the cashier says you can't use it
and then they storm away and they're
very very mad and then she tells her
husband what happened and the husband
takes the side of the girls and says
that she was in the wrong okay
i can see where your husband is is
coming from this is like something this
is like something my wife might do
and um
and i would probably be in your heart
especially if i was with her and and she
was planning on i would be in your
husband's shoes saying no just stay out
of it you know that's her dad's problem
it's not our problem we got enough
problems okay we don't need to add more
to the plate just whatever it's not our
problem
um so i would be with with with your
husband except that
what would propel me to not want to get
involved is is really indifference it's
not actually any sort of ethical
position so ultimately
while you're moderately an [ __ ] for
this it's a justified
whole situation like to knark on the kid
that way yeah you're kind of an a-hole
but it's also justified and i and i
really admire it
so that's one of the problems i have i
guess with sorting through some of these
is that i sort of admire people who
sometimes depending on the situation who
are willing to be a-holes in public uh
so there's a third category
of justified
polishness that i think is that's a
nuance that's missing from the am i the
a whole dilemma so i guess the final
messages that we should take from this
is um
it's okay to be an a-hole but but only
in the right situation well if you
enjoyed that content and you don't want
to be an [ __ ] yourself then do the
right thing and make sure to subscribe
and hit the like button right now hit it
hit it right now